é é gente da noite e não liga pra com 6
estrelas na alma
[Música]
a fonte da vida
cansa e que action madrugar que canta
que chora chora que só à noite
é gente
é da noite é que não liga
é um preconceito e estrelas na
a lua dentro do agente da vida
cansada e que é desse mundo a madrugada
[Música]
que khan thai que chora chora de saudade
quando a noite chorar de saudade vai
embora a short de saudade quando a noite
embora
obrigada bom é o senhor bibliothek sou
estudante de música sou compositora e
encanto pra acompanhar aqui é essa
música que eu escolhi pra começar dentro
escolher agora antes de entrar e pensei
que têm alguma ligação com a cidade
porque não é minha é do túlio piva que é
um compositor samus sambista gaúcho já
falecido bem atuante na década de 70 e
80 em porto alegre eo futuro ele a
relação dele com a cidade não era só ter
tido um bar que era urgente da noite é
mas ele era farmacêutico farmacêutico
aqui pertinho aqui no centro
e nunca nunca deixou de ser farmacêutico
nunca deixou de ter os amigos é nanã
drogas na rua da praia é então essa essa
canção diz muito sobre isso sobre alguém
que trabalha de dia e com qualquer coisa
tão importante quanto a música mas à
noite é vive disso eu me identifico
muito e agora vou tocar uma música que é
do meu primeiro disco que chama dengue
e ela chama três por quatro
é o que era
é
[Música]
veja bem o saco do contrária
eu tô as promessas entendeu tudo errado
e se for pra escolher um lugar pra
acreditar
certamente o corpo será a a
a cada pai já proferiu seu caminho
é porque já tenho meu amorim feito téo
que sóbis ou até cima pacote da tua
consciência
ó
é um difícil de lei e quem sabe eu sou
até se uma parte da tua adolescência g
mar que não sabe
insiste em brincar com a minha atenção
olhe a de boca
acho pode ver no castelo cair alegria
acontecer pode ir pode voltar a show
pode ver no castelo cair
[Música]
[Aplausos]
então tô presença me leva a efeito a
força que trará um tempo até senti quali
aço
ao voltar ao seu lugar se puder me ver o
baixo suspiros e não aceito eu juro que
eu tinha no pes pachá vi em toda minha
conclusão pêras a mystore a entrar água
me espera
as 96 banho pra eu poder chegar na
dimensão onde se encontrava nessa vida
vai passar amanhã a insistirem a cascar
juntar plurais qualquer teste servirá
pra pedir eu gosto de anis não gastar na
boca
[Música]
sentindo davis você vem testa minha
força de querer ser a coisa que te deixe
a quem merecer viver da sua coragem sua
vida vai passar amanhã vai insistir no
buscar em juntar pura aí me qualquer ps
seguirá pedindo teu rosto de nanismo
[Música]
eu tenho uma história como ted eu não
vim aqui para palestrar mas eu já estou
palestrando nem que me conhece sabe que
não resiste a uma palestra e antes de
tocar a última música é eu tenho um
tempo atrás eu eu sempre sempre fui da
música sempre foi uma pessoa da música
estudava na escola estudar violino na
escola em porto alegre e tudo mais mas
eu não enxergava o quanto a música já
tinha já tinha de música no meu dia e eu
estava terminando o colégio eu não sabia
o que ia fazer se não sabia e um amigo
falou não vai fazer das músicas não sei
o que é música licenciatura para ser
professor e tal
legal isso não é coisa para as pessoas e
eu não eu não eu não acreditava não
imaginava que eu pudesse entrar numa
faculdade de música porque eu pensava
que era capaz de aprender tudo que eu
precisaria aprender para poder ensinar
alguém
foi quando eu caí num vídeo no youtube
de do tex do gustavo reis que é um
professor de matemática e conta como ele
escolheu ser professor é ele diz uma
frase que que foi decisiva para mim
porque eu tinha muito medo de não
conseguir aprender tudo o que eu achava
que eu precisava aprender para ensinar
alguém e ele disse que pra ser um mestre
para ser um professor ou se é um mestre
basta você ensinar alguma coisa alguém e
hoje eu estou me informando que vem
licenciatura em música eu acho que o tek
tem uma participação nisso a cimpor
talvez daí aquele recadinho lá no final
que eu precisava ouvir e e hoje eu sei
mais que isso que todos os dias a gente
aprende alguma coisa eu saio de casa pra
aprender alguma coisa então eu vou tocar
a idéia agora é muito obrigado pelos
olhares atentos de vocês muito obrigado
sedex muito obrigado meninos aí que
ajudaram
a glória foi o dia o bicho verme aorta
ai ai meu deus do céu que eu sofria
houver a natureza morta
ai ai meu deus do céu que eu sofreu ver
a natureza morta de mandioca para a
farinha e emílio pra galinha eo cap para
branquinha e um feijão quem compra gosta
de ea mandioca para a farinha m para
galinha eu pintar a vaquinha e o feijão
quem comprar gó
[Música]
o velório vai aonde eu mexo perry minha
horta
ai ai meu deus do céu eu sofri alger a
natureza morta
ai ai meu deus do céu que o sofia vera
natureza amor para demonstrar a minha
alegria fiz tremenda gritaria
em noite grey dia e até ficar na roça
para demonstrar a minha alegria
ferimento gritaria e em noite irei tia
dei até fascar ó
[Música]
ai ai ai o dia o bicho larry me a rota
ai ai meu deus do céu quanto eu sofri o
ver no treino do bota
ai ai meu deus do céu conta sofreu verão
natureza morta
obrigado
[Aplausos]